[Musique]
depuis le début de la pandémie on est
quotidiennement bombardée de chiffres ou
le savez plusieurs ont même intégré
leurs routiers d'un petit coup d'oeil
matinale au plus récent bilan des décès
dus à la coved 19
mais jusqu'à quel point ces données sont
un portrait fidèle de la situation
certains en doutent au point où il un
peu aux autorités la volonté de gonflé
volontairement les chiffres pour faire
peur à la population et je suis de
confinement il enregistre des morts
comme ça pour faire gonfler les chiffres
je juge que geof montres lip duo est ce
qu il l'admettre la chaîne radio québec
animé par alexis que cette rude elle
incarne bien cette mouvance
présent sur youtube son web journal
intitulé la fraude statistiques
confirment et a été visionnée plus d'un
demi million de fois en l'espace d'un
mois
andré pitre est un autre de ces
pourfendeurs des données officielles sur
les décès liés à la coved 19 mai venez
pas me dire à moins que sa plus grande
pandémie qu'on a vécu quand vous mettez
n'importe qui qui tous pierre yeux
rouges dans le cockpit 19 puis que vous
faites pas de test ceux qui sont
provoquées leur indignation basse et la
proche du québec d'inclusion des liens
épidémiologiques dans le calcul des
décès recommandé depuis la fin avril par
l' oms cette approche a été adopté par
de nombreux pays l'espagne le
royaume-uni l'italie la corée du sud et
j'en passe selon l'institut de la santé
publique du québec 1,99 confirmée par
lien épidémiologique
ça correspond à une personne qui n'a pas
été testée mais qui a développé des
symptômes tels que de la fièvre de la
toux chronique exacerbée de la
difficulté respiratoire après avoir été
en contact à risque élevé avec un cas
confirmé de com et 19 ça peut être
colloque un conjoint ou conjointe ou
oneda naturelles par exemple
selon les experts de l oms le principe
derrière cette approche est notamment
basée sur le fait qu'un nombre croissant
de données montrent que les personnes
souffrant de maladies chroniques ou de
déficit immunitaire mais présentent un
risque plus élevé de décéder de la com
et 19
d'autre part dans bien des pays la
pandémie s'accompagne d'un nombre limité
de tests de dépistage disponible
autrement dit en temps normal on peut
davantage tester tout le monde en temps
de pandémie
bah c'est pas mal plus difficile
en somme contrairement à ce qu'affirme
ceux qui doutent de la véracité des
données officielles
les bilans des autorités sanitaires
sous-estiment plus qu'elle ne surestime
les statistiques sur les décès pour plus
de détails sur ce dossier consulté mon
article sur notre page web ou encore
dans notre groupe facebook
et n'oubliez pas d'écouter l'émission
des décrypteurs diffuser la fin de
semaine samedi et dimanche sur les ondes
et 6 rbds et sur ceux vous à lui
[Musique]